[Musique]
des routes et des ponts engloutis par
des tornades
hier dans le gard tout à commencer par
cette vague une onde de crues qui a tout
balayé sur son passage
ces épisodes un risque d'être de plus en
plus fréquentes et de plus en plus
violents et donc là ça ça il faut qu'on
se prépare non seulement d'abord tout
travail qu'on fait pour baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
aussi pour que nos territoires sache
mieux résisté c'est un rituel pour de
nombreux toulousains se rassembler sur
les bords de la garonne pour prendre un
verre mais désormais sur arrêté
préfectoral
la consommation d'alcool est interdite
ici et dans tous les espaces publics de
la ville dès 13h on a appris ce week-end
que bruno le maire était en confinement
pendant une semaine
il a été testé positif même s'il est
asymptomatique vous même vous vous êtes
fait tester
non je me suis pas fait tester ce nouvel
arrêté interdit également toute activité
dansante
les concerts et les activités musicales
et la consommation debout dans les
restaurants et les bars gouvernement si
les règles sont les mêmes comme pour
tous les français c'est à dire que quand
vous êtes un cas contacts vous fait
tester je ne voulais pas été avec bruno
le maire donc je me suis pas fait tester
et ça fait huit mois la plaisanterie
maintenant peut-être arrêter non de
faire juste n'importe quoi et d'être des
amateurs
ça fait huit mois que ça a démarré
depuis le mois de jeu de janvier dernier
on aurait dû se mettre en situation
on n'a pas été en situation de porter
des masques on n'a pas été en situation
d'apporter des tests on était tellement
mauvais qu'on est obligés d'enfermer les
gens pendant deux mois chez eux rien n'a
été organisé non plus cherchent eux
voient c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas de
lits supplémentaires il n'ya pas le
personnel dont on aurait besoin
l'appel à la vaccination massive contre
la grippe 75 députés signe une tribune
dans le journal du dimanche pour eux
c'est un acte citoyen afin d'éviter que
la grippe ne s'ajoute à la pandémie de
kobe de 19
parce que si vous avez à coville et vous
pensez avoir la grippe alors là je ne
vous dis pas ce que ça représente en
terme de contagion donc il faut vraiment
que le gouvernement dans une campagne
positive mais massivement contestons le
maximum quand pendant testons vous voyez
sinon le maximum de personnes contre la
grippe saisonnière nous n'avons qu'une
chose à faire nous battre nous battre
nous battre pour tous nos concitoyens
qui sont aujourd'hui dans l' angoisse de
perdre leur travail ou parfois dans le
désarroi quand ils l'ont perdu pour
leurs familles pour leurs enfants nous
battre pour eux et avec eux nouveau
sondage sur la côte de popularité des
manuels macron elle progresse légèrement
en septembre 38% d'opinions positives
non à la fin leur donne des sous en leur
disant qu'ils aient pour la
compétitivité pour l'emploi il ya ni
l'augmentation des cas d angleterre et
éclat le cas est particulièrement criant
il dit maintenant ils fabriquent des
pneus qui sert plus à rien d'être ali
penser avant vous appelleriez le patron
de la bad de la boîte et vous lui diriez
je ne veux pas et ce serait aussi
facilement et des ah ça c'est sûr qu'en
tout cas je lui dirai qu'il envisage de
mener une action pour qu'il rembourse
l'argent public qui l'a touché je peux
d'ores et déjà vous annoncer que les
salariés les organisations syndicales
ont signé un accord de méthode
vendredi qui d'abord donne cinq mois la
discussion et qui réouvre des scénarios
alternatifs à la fermeture de l'usiné
il faut être candidat pour présenter un
projet de société vous l'êtes expliqué
je suis plus préparé qu'il y a quelques
mois pas encore autant que dans que dans
20 mois
mais je veux dire que l'expérience que
j'ai pu j'ai pu acquérir dans mes
différentes fonctions d'élu local ce
très important d'être élu local saisi
bertrand où il ne savait pas que
bridgestone allait fermer
et c'est très grave parce que les
ouvriers eux ils le savaient et alors il
est déconnecté il n'a pas assumé ou
alors il le savait parce que il est dans
cette logique là et il est complice
c'est un peu tard se réveiller même la
très grande intelligence
elle remplace pas l'expérience et puis
ensuite c'est de comprendre aussi que
les français veulent être compris
protéger ça fait déjà le début d'un
chemin avec ce qui se passe y compris ce
qui se passe dans la région de zahlé
bertrand on n'imaginait pas que ce
serait les déclarations de candidature à
la présidentielle qui serait le plus
urgent
affaire